hey how's it going Brad as my name is
today we're going to play some Mortal
Kombat and we're going to check out all
the fatalities of each of the characters
if you don't know every character has a
finishing move which is pretty goddamn
gory so if you're not up for that feel
free to click out but we're gonna get
this [ __ ] going let's start off yes yes
ah and it's in good ol gar baby
hang out oh oh maybe I look a little
flower how it is go flowerpot [ __ ]
beautiful we go come on baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
you still here alrights [ __ ] now hey I
love my girl it's just gonna drag your
wrench
[Music]
well now you can look at your ass
well present for you my friend why blow
up his head then hey a Christmas
ornament
moving on to King she's there we go -
this is I guess in one
there we go dark fantasy why God should
begin oh [ __ ] where's your hands breath
[Music]
splitting hairs
that's that's a great photo
what happened to the face hey some wall
ornaments zero time [ __ ] that's
pretty badass time nice we just get
worse and worse something
Oh finally he's fine I was a [ __ ] head
cage fatality this one perfect I've seen
this one and it's [ __ ] awesome just
blow a bubble with our forehead
[Music]
there we go yes beautiful Oh sassy so
[ __ ] beautiful velvet we are amused
tasty Queen milena she committed herself
nice Gordo yeah probably not even dead
damn girl I love that undercut all right
we got two more jerky ribs all right go
toke that [ __ ] baddies and the final
one for this episode will be
oh yeah I like how I question bow on out
of all of them that's one dress what a
great finisher oh I oppressed you want
to see the remaining of the half leave a
like and really appreciate it click here
to watch it now it was tough already
there was so much watching and as always
stay awesome
[Music]